No way…
Master Yoh.
It's still too early, is it not?
No. I've had plenty of sleep.
Anyways,
it's been a while since we've
taken a stroll, just the two of us.
I remember this feeling.
A fresh, crisp morning like this…
I haven't enjoyed one
since we were in Funbari Hill.
Right.
It all ends today, huh?
Funny, isn't it? All I wanted
was to have it easy,
and look where I am now.
Amidamaru.
Thanks for everything, really.
Where has all this come from?
-The time for thanks is--
-It's not too early.
After all, becoming Shaman King
means dying.
Hao is presently in the sleep of death,
waiting for the time
he becomes Shaman King.
Once he's the Shaman King, I'm not going
to get out of a fight with him unscathed.
Master Yoh…
But then, Ms. Anna…
Come on!
She's long since been ready for this.
Everyone dies, sooner or later.
That's why we don't live
to live a long life.
We live to die properly.
Amidamaru.
Today will be the true final battle.
Once again, I'm counting on you.
As you wish!
Oh, boy.
I thought you'd vanished on us,
but here you are.
We were sure you'd run off to Hao
on your lonesome again.
Oh, you guys are all up early.
Of course.
Early bird gets the worm.
Good morning, Yoh!
Looks like another fine day!
We're all back in fighting shape!
We'll have to thank Kalim.
He even baked us some bread!
Come on, let's all
have breakfast together!
Sure!